thousands of people across the north of
england and scotland are still without
power that's a week on from storm arwen
and according to the energy secretary
quasi-quatting uh climate change will
make extreme weather events like this
all the more common it means that the
focus is once again on resilience and
how where we live needs to be adapted to
withstand the climate change dame julia
if we're going to have these big
electrification projects we need an
electricity
infrastructure which is sturdy and
doesn't fall over don't we
we absolutely do because
as we move to net zero we change our
fuel use quite dramatically so at the
moment about 15 percent of our energy
comes from electricity
as we get towards net zero that'll move
to 60 to 70 percent of our of our energy
coming from electricity so it will be
absolutely crucial um that our
electricity system is resilient because
when the electricity fails everything
will stop
and we know that that things like storm
are when are going to be coming more
common um as the climate continues to
change and of course it will continue to
change until we get to net zero and i
said uh even on the eve of cop 26 we saw
the train lines uh let loads of us down
stranded us all um compared to other
global cities how are the cities in the
uk uh faring do you think in terms of
infrastructure for that transition
so as uh iggy your previous guests were
saying look no no cities infrastructure
is fit for purpose when dealing with
this climate crisis and of course these
impacts are much deeper and happening
far worse in countries of the global
south we don't have the capacity of the
resources to be able to deal with them
but you take indonesia for example
they're now planning to move their city
jakarta their capital city we've seen
you know from dhaka to new york to
venice to bangkok all of these cities
under threat and it's not simply about
our energy infrastructure here in london
if you remember we had heavy rainfall
and our tube
system
i'm sorry to jump in there assad we are
out of time